my sister the hero a garden of the
galaxy guardians of the galaxy
why would we be the gardens of the
galaxy the family like this
your people I wish sodium's of the
galaxy vol 2 is pretty pg-13 50% 110
they go pink you are me star much I'm
not gonna answer star much on May 5th
what you see Papa you only get one
chance
the galaxy twice oh wow I know and
almost hit me
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 pretty
pg-13 the sovereign the Ravagers
they all want us dead that's a really
bad sign
the guardians are destroyed
and hit me with your best shot
oh wow I know and almost hit me get
tickets now don't put your seatbelts on
sky pushup yes
that was awesome so here we are at Steve
one thugs and assassin a maniac and an
angry little tree hold on
so we're saving the galaxy again
although else is gonna do it
the Guardians cannot protect the galaxy
oh there must be some kind of peaceful
resolution to this or even a violent one
where I'm standing over there
onions of the galaxy vol 2 get tickets
now the wielding an IMAX 3d
you